I love the gifts between Haymitch and  Effie I like to think that maybe there  huh it might be something they're never  done take care of I will I have a crush  on Elizabeth Banks I'm not gonna lie I  think she's a beautiful woman I think  she's a marvelous actress and I just  love her as a person she's as fun as can  be she didn't know I was even gonna do  it and I just kissed her and then she's  such a pro you know so when we did it it  wasn't like just a light thing where we  thought it was nothing is really like  okay well this is you know and and  hopefully you know once we did the  sequel of this that no one's expecting  including the author you know they sent  my pickup of his to